>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good afternoon and welcome.
Thanks for coming to this session.
I'm Amy Stolls.
I'm the director of literature at
the National Endowment for the Arts,
which is one of the
sponsors or the main sponsor
of this stage for poetry and prose.
And I'm thrilled to have Brad Watson
and Bill Roorbach with
us here today.
Bill from Maine -- western?
>> Bill Roorbach: Western Maine.
>> Western Maine.
And Brad from Wyoming
via Mississippi, Alabama,
a whole bunch of places, right?
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
>> I should say -- and we met
in Mississippi many years ago.
So I still think of you
as that southern writer,
even though you're
up west, up north.
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
>> So we're excited about this.
This is sort of an experiment for
us, that we are starting a new kind
of conversation between writers
where I'm going to introduce them
and then step off the stage happily
so that you can hear
them talk to each other.
They've known each other --
we put them together because you
have known -- you've met before.
I assume you like each
other, so I hope.
And you'll -- yeah, well, okay.
I like you, so I'm rooting for
the good conversations there.
I will also say that they
are both NEI fellows,
which means they received
$25,000 fellowships
through the National
Endowment for the Arts,
which is a really competitive
process
of selecting anonymously talent,
particularly emerging talent.
And we get 1,800 applications and we
only give between 35 and 40 awards.
So you have before
you two NEI fellows.
I --
[ Applause ]
So Bill Roorbach, an
award-winning author of nine books?
You keep count?
Yeah, of fiction, short stories, and
novels, a memoir, a book of craft.
He is going to talk
about his latest today,
The Girl of the Lake,
a book of short stories.
Fantastic.
You also might also know him from
The Remedy of Love, was a finalist
for the Kirkus prize; or the
best-selling Life Among Giants,
another novel, winner of
the Maine Literary Award;
a book of short stories, Big Bend.
His memoir is called Temple
Stream; and among other books.
But The Girl of the Lake,
this latest and fantastic book
of short stories,
critically-acclaimed,
Booklist starred review,
for example, said,
"Each meticulously chiseled down and
polished tale contains enough plot,
character development, and
emotion to fill a novel.
These stories, with their smart and
funny dialogue, characters both wise
and fallible are sure to capture
the reader's imagination and heart."
Publisher's Weekly said
of it, "The ten generous,
daring short stories range from
tricky romance to dark comedy,
to breath-taking adventure.
And they start off ordinary and
then turn magically strange."
So I'm excited to hear
him talk about that.
Brad Watson is the
Guggenheim fellow,
also author of four
critically-acclaimed books.
He will be talking about
Miss Jane, his novel,
made the National Book
Award long list.
You might also him from
The Heaven of Mercury,
which was a finalist novel
for the National Book Award.
He has his book of short
stories Aliens in the Prime
of Their Lives, the finalist for
the PEN/Faulkner Award for fiction.
And Last Days of the
Dog-Men, which was his first
and won the Sue Kaufman
award for First Fiction
from the American Academy
of Arts and Letters.
And he teaches at the
University of Wyoming --
I hope I'm getting this all right --
in Laramie and was recently selected
to receive the Harper Lee Award
for Alabama's Distinguished
Writer of the Year for 2017.
And Library Journal, a
star-review critical acclaim --
I'm just giving you a taste --
writes, "As Watson arcs through the
story of Jane's life and sensitive,
beautifully precise prose, we
are both absorbed and humbled."
And I'm going to read a
paragraph from a terrific review
in the New York Times book review
because it says a lot, quote,
"The complexity and drama
of Watson's gorgeous work
here is life's as well.
Sometimes physical realities
expand us, sometimes trap.
Sometimes heroism lies in
combating our helplessness,
sometimes in accepting it.
A writer of profound emotional
depths, Watson does not lie
to his readers, so
neither does his Jane.
She never stops longing for a
wholeness she may never know,
but she is determined that
her citizenship in the world,
however onerous be dragged into
the light and there be lived
without apology or
perfection or pity."
And with that, I'm going to
step down and let them to it.
Thank you.
>> Bill Roorbach: Thank you.
>> Brad Watson: Thank you, Amy.
[ Applause ]
>> Brad Watson: Hello, Bill.
>> Bill Roorbach: Hi, Brad.
>> Brad Watson: It was great
having brunch with you today.
>> Bill Roorbach: It was great
having bunch with you today.
>> Brad Watson: Bill created
a new dish at The Burn.
Just wanted to say that.
[ Laughter ]
>> Bill Roorbach: I just had
them put an egg on my tacos.
>> Brad Watson: Everybody
was impressed, though.
>> Bill Roorbach: So
a couple of weeks --
I don't know, months ago actually,
my Aunt Patsy called
me, my mother's -- oh.
[ Laughter ]
Someone says they can't hear me.
>> Brad Watson: Is that
because your mic is drooping?
You might have to button
another button or something.
[ Laughter ]
>> Bill Roorbach: I appreciate
the sartorial approach.
[ Laughter ]
I'll put it up higher.
Is that better?
Oh, good.
>> Brad Watson: It's blocking.
The shirt's blocking it.
[ Laughter ]
>> Bill Roorbach: I'm just
going to take my shirt off.
>> Brad Watson: Do you need
some help there [Laughs]?
>> Bill Roorbach: Well.
[ Laughter ]
I like this, this is good.
A couple of months ago,
my Aunt Patsy called me.
She's close to 90, she's the last
of my mother's surviving siblings.
There were eight of them
-- one died in childhood,
and the others have
made it all the way
to very old age, one
by one passing away.
It's very sad.
But Aunt Patsy called me.
Well, there were two --
Bessie's still around, too.
So Aunt Patsy called me and said,
"Bill, I'm sorry to call you
and tell you this, but your
Aunt Bessie has passed away."
And I was like, "Oh no."
And I just had this terrible
sad feeling and guilt
because I hadn't called
her for a while.
And I thought, "I meant to call
her, like, the Sunday before
and I just had forgotten."
And so anyway, I called her son,
one of my cousins, and said,
"I'm so sorry to hear
about your mom."
And he goes, "What?
What happened?"
And I go, "Well, Patsy called me
and said that your mother had died."
And he goes, "Oh, no.
Oh my God.
I got to get down there."
And then a couple of days later,
he calls me back and says, "Bill,
I went down to Palo Alto" --
they're out in California --
"and my mother was fine."
[ Laughter ]
And so I called Aunt Patsy
and she said she didn't remember
calling anyone, you know?
So then Aunt Patsy calls me another
couple of days later and says,
"Bill, I'm so sorry that I
told you Aunt Bessie was dead.
I had a dream that she was dead."
[ Laughter ]
"And I called simply everyone."
So -- so --
>> Brad Watson: So that's
where you're from [Laughs].
>> Bill Roorbach: That's
where I'm from.
So they all had an aunt named
Aunt Molly who had been stepped
on by a horse when she was a little
girl and her face was crushed.
So they grew up with this
aunt who -- she survived --
but they grew up with this
special person, you know,
who nevertheless led
a fairly normal life.
And I just felt like Brad reading
about Miss Jane with her challenge,
it just -- and the milieu,
too, the era; all the secrets
that attended any health thing;
and the sense of family and how
that settled into a place.
I just felt so connected
to your book.
I think because of my
family's story but also
because it's such an American story.
What -- is Miss Jane based
on someone like my Molly?
>> Brad Watson: She was inspired
by a great aunt, my mother's aunt.
And -- but I never knew her.
I saw her -- my great Aunt Jane --
once when I was a little boy
when we were at my grandmother's
for our weekly Sunday gathering
for my mother's family.
She was helped into the
house by another uncle.
She was wearing Sunday black.
She was very frail.
And everyone said,
"Well, that's Aunt Jane."
And it was known somehow that,
you know, something is wrong,
you know, with Aunt Jane.
>> Bill Roorbach: Just something?
>> Brad Watson: Just something.
You know, over the years,
you know, my mom said --
let me know that for her
entire life she was incontinent
and that she never
married and had children.
And so it had something
-- it was some sort of --
apparently some sort of urogenital
anomaly, you know, birth defect.
But no one knew any details, at
least no one alive knew any details.
And there were no medical
records or anything like that.
I was inspired.
I was always fascinated by her
because everyone said she was a
really cheerful person in spite
of having to live with things
that most people don't.
And I was going through a box of
photographs one day with my mom
at home, old photographs,
and I saw a picture
of this attractive young woman or
older teenage girl wearing a sun hat
and looking back at the camera.
And she had this sort of
coquettish look, you know?
I said, "Who's that?"
She said, "Well, that's Aunt Jane."
I said, "It almost looks like
she's flirting with someone."
And she said -- my
mom said, "Well, yeah.
She was -- Aunt Jane was
really popular with the boys."
I said, "Well, how did
she manage that, you know,
with her condition in those days?"
She said, "I have no idea."
[ Laughter ]
And she said, "But she used
to go to the dances up there
in the Damascus community where
she grew up in the country,"
and where my mom grew up
also right across the road.
I said, "Went to dances?
And you told me that you got in
trouble as a child for laughing
because she squeaked when she
walked because of rubber underwear,
protective garments she had to
wear, and she went to dances?"
I said, "How did she do that?"
"Oh, I have no idea."
And I started thinking about it.
I thought -- it made
me think, "Okay,
this is not just a poor
old maid Aunt Jane."
She had a life.
She was a real person and started
trying to see beyond just her
as the other, you know, the
person with the condition,
and try to imagine a life.
Unfortunately, I had to imagine
more than I thought I would.
I thought there would be a
lot of great family stories,
there would be records,
more photographs,
someone would know
what her condition was.
And no one did.
No one did.
I basically ended up having to make
up just about everything, which was,
of course, just a novel and it
was better in the end for that.
>> Bill Roorbach: Well, it reads
as the truest of true, you know?
You found your way into
first the young woman --
the kid's life and then
the young woman's life.
My favorite passages are as
she's coming of age, you know,
and starting to grapple with
sexuality and attractions to boys
and yet she doesn't have the
usual sexual equipment, you know?
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
>> Bill Roorbach: So I
thought it was, you know,
she's kind of the female Jake
Barnes for our time, you know?
But it was -- it was --
>> Brad Watson: Well, as I
was saying earlier, of course,
the thing that finally worked itself
out in a good way I thought was
that her condition is such that
she has everything she's supposed
to have.
>> Bill Roorbach: She
has all the internal --
>> Brad Watson: Without access
to it and no surgical ability
in those days to correct
it, to bring everything.
>> Bill Roorbach: There's
no way to fix that?
>> Brad Watson: No way
to fix it in that time.
In fact, my great Aunt
was born in 1888;
Jane in the book is born in 1915.
And the first successful correction
of that surgery happened in '85.
My great aunt died in '78.
And in the book, Jane is --
this is well into her 60's when she
gets news there's a possibly of it.
So [inaudible].
But speaking of Jane and
-- another thing of my mom.
So my mom [Laughs], I said, "I
want to go find Aunt Jane's grave."
She said, "Oh, okay.
I know where it is."
She told me where it is in the
cemetery by this tree on this hill."
Okay. I went there and
I looked and I found it.
I couldn't see Jane Clay anywhere.
I went back and I said,
"I couldn't find it.
There's a headstone for a
woman named Mary Ellis Clay
with about the right dates on it."
She said, "Oh, yeah.
That's her."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Well, it doesn't
say Mary Ellis Jane Clay."
I said, "Why did they
call her Jane?"
She said, "I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
>> Bill Roorbach: That gets me, too.
>> Brad Watson: So
that's where I'm from.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah, that's where
-- Aunt Patsy's real name in Laura.
What -- why --
>> Brad Watson: I had a aunt
named Laura, a great aunt.
>> Bill Roorbach: You did?
A Laura?
>> Brad Watson: Yeah, a Laura.
Yeah.
>> Bill Roorbach: So did you have
to do research to find a condition
that you could reasonably assume
was the condition of your aunt
and then go ahead and
fictionalize from there?
>> Brad Watson: Yeah, all
the most common conditions,
I read the giant tome published
in about 1940 by Dr. Hugh Young,
who was a peripheral offstage
character in the book.
He was a pioneering
urologist at John's Hopkins.
And there was nothing in
there that really worked,
you know, seemed to be right.
And all the most common
conditions I could find,
none of them seemed to be right.
Most of them involved a lot of
infections, and constant trips
to the doctor, and
maybe an early death.
And my aunt did not have to do that,
didn't suffer in that particular
way, and lived a long life.
So I finally found
this one and it fit.
And this was something -- oh,
once I said to my mom, I said,
"Do you think she was intersexual?"
You know? "No, no, she was a woman."
My mother was indignant that
I would ask that question.
So I said okay, I'll go
with that assumption.
And this condition also happens
only in women, in females.
So everything kind
of -- I finally --
it took a long time
because it's pretty rare.
And it took a long time to find
something that not only seemed
to be right on a character based
on my aunt, and I wanted it
to be a condition that
would create a life that was
like the one I could try to
imagine her having and that --
I'm sorry, I lost that thought.
>> Bill Roorbach: I love
the doctor you invent, too,
because he's so caring
and so interested.
It's a scientific anomaly,
so that catches his interest.
But he's so -- he offers
all of the caring and love
that her family doesn't
know how to offer.
So just great characters
all the way through.
>> Brad Watson: After he loses his
wife -- even before that, though,
because his marriage
is not so great.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah.
>> Brad Watson: Which leads to him
later saying to her that, you know,
sometimes some people
should follow their nature.
Some people aren't
-- should be alone.
It's not necessarily such
a terrible thing, you know?
It can be a good thing.
>> Bill Roorbach: It
can be a good thing.
>> Brad Watson: Yeah, yeah.
>> Bill Roorbach: And that
brings us to she lives on a farm
that feels so big and so real.
And she has places on the farm like
the river that she can go out to
and the field, rather, where --
>> Brad Watson: Yeah, her meadow.
>> Bill Roorbach: Her meadow.
>> Brad Watson: Her meadow.
Her meadow.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah.
>> Brad Watson: Well, you know,
I've been in Wyoming 12 years now.
When I was writing Heaven to
Mercury set in the same --
set in the town near where Jane
is set, I was living in Boston.
But I had more recently
lived in the South.
And also, I was writing
about a small urban area
that I grew up in, in Newell.
And now I had been in
Wyoming, you know, for ten --
well, when I got to writing
the drafts in earnest --
because it took me a long time and
a lot of false starts to figure
out how to write it -- but I think
it was 2013 or so when I figured
out how to write it, and
there were many drafts to go.
But I started.
And by that time I had
been out there already
for seven or eight years.
And plus, this was a farm, and
I did not grow up on a farm.
So I would go home and go to the
land where my mother grew up,
which is now covered in trees and
all kind of overgrowth, undergrowth.
And I had visited there
when there was still ruins.
And so I knew where to go in
the woods to be in that spot.
And my mother had told me -- I
had gone there and I'd say, "Okay,
well, here was the house.
This is all woods, and
where was the cattle pond?
I know where -- you know,
where's the swimming pond?
Where's the fishing pond?"
She'd said say, "Well, we planted
tobacco here, a little corn here.
There was a large cornfield.
There was a little cotton
we had here, you know?
And there was the shed and
there was the barn," and so on.
And so I had to just construct
kind of a, you know, this --
I drew pictures for
myself and then I would go.
And I would go to the place
and just smell it and feel it,
you know what I mean, in the
air and listen to bird song.
>> Bill Roorbach: And
it's kind of a dream
that grows in your imagination.
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
But I had to go and be there
because it wasn't as easy
to conjure without the visits.
It wasn't easy to get
it -- fix it in my head.
You know, you spend a long -- you
go through several drafts, you know,
and part of the effort in
those drafts is getting
to where you can really see through
the characters, through the eyes
of those characters
to see that place.
And then it becomes -- then
you stop thinking about it,
that you're not doing
it consciously,
and then you're probably pretty
close to being in the groove.
>> Bill Roorbach: At that point.
>> Brad Watson: But
it takes a while.
>> Bill Roorbach: Once
you're imagining it?
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
>> Bill Roorbach: Do you want
to read a little bit for us or?
>> Brad Watson: I can read
now or we can talk some
about yours or I don't know.
We can do that, and then
we'll talk all about you.
How about that?
>> Bill Roorbach: Sound good to me.
>> Brad Watson: Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>> Bill Roorbach: I'd
love to hear you read.
>> Brad Watson: I don't
want to take too much time.
Okay. This is -- all right.
So I had to imagine how my
great aunt might have gone
to these dances.
And I thought, "Well, how did
she go without having an accident
as she calls it in the book?"
And so I just thought, I
said, "Well, what would I do?"
And this is about that,
her first dance.
For an entire two days before the
evening of the dance, she fasted.
First thing on the first morning
she dosed herself with castor oil,
followed by a little buttermilk just
to have something on her stomach
and stayed in the privy until
she felt herself emptied out.
She spent the next entire day
beneath the tree in the middle
of the pecan grove or beside the
fishing pond or lying in the middle
of her favorite little
clearing in the woods.
She would take along a
piece of bread, maybe bacon
but scatter the bread for the
birds, toss the bacon to the fish,
not thinking -- just being or simply
being Jane as when she was younger.
On the first day she
would allow herself
to sip a little water
from time to time.
At some point in the second
day there would be an almost
hallucinatory clarity in her
vision, in the presence of things
around her, in the sounds of birds
and farm work and dogs barking,
sounds of livestock
and people talking.
Even the breezes gently rustling
leaves in the trees made a sound
that seemed to fill her
mind in an intoxicating way,
as if the very tips of the leaves
were tickling her awareness.
The temptation of the senses that
she allowed to wash through her,
to flush her with calm anticipation.
This had not just a little to do
with her strange alluring
grace in those days.
She walked about in such
a dreamy, distracted state
that her mother let her know that
she'd check her laudanum bottle
to make sure the girl
had not got into it.
[ Laughter ]
The afternoon before her first
dance her mother said to her,
"You can't get too friendly
with these boys, Jane."
Jane said nothing, just
listening, oddly calm in her way
that her mother seemed
to find unsettling.
So she went on, "Do you understand?
You've long known it."
When Jane only smiled, her stood up
in mild exasperation to walk away
and as she did, she said,
"You have to be careful.
It might not only be
you that gets hurt."
"But Dr. Thompson said he believes
they'll be able to fix me one day.
I could have a regular
life with a man someday,"
though he hadn't said exactly that.
Her mother stopped and looked
at her long and steady,
"Believing is a matter of
faith," she said, "not certainty."
Jane had never seen the look
in her eye she saw then.
She looked almost empty.
And for the first time Jane
could remember she saw her mother
as a woman whom life had made
not just hard but also exhausted
and plain, older looking
than her years.
Then as if she could read the
unspoken words in Jane's eyes,
her mother's expression
darkened again.
Her own eyes glistened
about to shed tears,
"What would you know
about life with a man?
And what of your little experience
in this world would make you
think it such a fine thing?"
Jane watched her go out the back
door, feeling more sad for her
than abashed at being abraded.
Her mother's words weren't able
to dispel the deeply
calm pleasure she felt
in these new days, this new self.
She didn't wear a diaper to the
dance, only a little padding as if
for possible light menstruation
so that there were no
bulky undergarments
to interrupt her slim figure
or graceful movements.
And she made herself a light, more
slim-fitting dress and wore a pair
of shoes her father had
bought for her in town
after drawing an outlined figure of
her foot on a sheet of school paper
to show the shoe salesman.
She attended two dances before
any of the boys got up the courage
or got past their bashful
curiosity to ask her to dance.
But that was good, since it
allowed her to study their movements
so she could mimic them later.
And then finally, Elijah
Key did ask her.
She'd seen him standing against the
wall in the shadows of dim lights
from the Japanese lanterns the
organizers had hung in the hall.
He wasn't wearing his glasses and
probably had no idea she was there.
A little later she saw him again,
spectacles on, looking at her.
Maybe someone had mentioned her.
Seeing her seemed to surprise
him into something like shyness.
Then when she let her attention
wander that second night,
wander as it tended to do in
her state of mind, she looked up
and there he was, standing
out in front of her
and holding out his hand.
After he danced with her,
some of the other boys also began
asking her out onto the floor.
She felt something that she'd
never felt before then --
the pleasure of flirtation, though
she didn't even know the word.
The boys liked her
and she liked them.
But if any one of them seemed
about to like her too much,
she had her way of
withdrawing just enough,
like a scrap of paper the wind
keeps blowing just out of reach.
Her oddly calm, distracted
stated seemed
to fascinate them into
stupid muteness.
And when she would fix
her gaze upon her partner,
that boy looked dumbstruck
as if thinking he might
be falling in love.
But she was so obviously
democratic in the dispensation
of her new strange charm
that none of them was moved
to any sort of foolish words.
She could see Elijah watching her
when she danced with other boys,
her light, thin figure in her
homemade dress, her straight,
dark hair and long and loose,
her darkling blue eyes.
She could the stick-thin
figure of her father, too,
hat held in the hand
in the moonlit doorway.
She kept a few sprigs of mint
leaves in the pocket of her dress,
chewed them gently, then
stored them in her cheek
as a man might a small
bit of chewing tobacco.
The mint kept her dehydration
from giving her bad breath
and drew what moisture there was in
her body to her mouth and her lips,
allowing some minimal conversation.
She smiled and laughed
with the boys who danced
with her and seemed happy.
In the pale quivering candlelight
their faces seemed luminous,
their voices melodic, just a bit out
of sync with the modest movements
of their lips and speech.
She was hardly even conscious of
how the other girls were now jealous
and certainly couldn't
be bothered to care.
It flickered in and
out of her awareness,
a coruscation of whispers
and glares.
When she danced with
Elijah Key she was happiest.
He would speak to her softly,
leaning close to her ear,
"How did you decide to
start coming out like this?
You're so pretty, but you
seem a little strange."
[ Laughter ]
"I am strange," she said.
So she delighted -- allowed herself
to be delighted in this attention,
in the public intimacy with
Elijah Key, in her flirtation
with other boys, in the flaunting
of herself before the other girls.
Even though she knew this was
something with no long life ahead
of it, she was able to press
into the moments of pleasure
in the movements of her own body.
She understood somehow that she
was lucky in her special way
to love these events without the
complicated, pressing question
of physical love, to absorb life
from the center and its periphery
at once, so she could
for a while take it all
in with the sweet fullness
of the entirely human
and the utterly strange
without apprehension of fear.
That was --
[ Applause ]
Thank you, thank you.
>> Bill Roorbach: I love how she
holds herself a little separate,
like the slip of paper
always blowing away
that you're trying to grab.
Beautiful.
>> Brad Watson: Yeah, I
loved writing that scene.
You know, once I got to it,
I really loved writing it.
I love the idea of
her figuring out how
to make herself a little bit
stoned, you know, on the --
>> Bill Roorbach: From
the privations.
>> Brad Watson: By deprivation
and that making her
more attractive, yeah.
So I really enjoyed it, writing it.
So Bill, this is one of the
best collections of stories
that I own and have read.
>> Bill Roorbach: Thanks.
>> Brad Watson: I mean,
these are beautiful.
These are beautiful -- they
are all beautiful stories.
And, you know, there's a grouchy
guy online who writes a blog
about short story, and
he gets really ticked off
when anyone says that, "This
story is like a novel."
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah [Laughs].
>> Brad Watson: Because he's
a fan of the short story
and not the novel, you know?
But there really is -- you
do build worlds, you know,
in these stories in a wonderful way.
And no -- I mean, and
in such different ways.
The opening story, Harbinger Hall,
is about a boy decides not just
to play hooky, but he
thinks he's going to be able
to pull off somehow
playing hooky forever.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah [Laughs].
>> Brad Watson: Thinks he's going to
be clever enough to pull that off,
you know, that no one will notice.
And then he comes across this
mansion and he spies on it,
and then he kind of gets caught by
almost kind of like a giant, right?
And then he's taken aside
and there's this old man.
And then the story becomes the
old man telling him the story
of the Russian Revolution -- or an
episode in the Russian Revolution.
And we come to realize that
he's telling his own story.
So the boy -- and how did you
come to decide to tell that story
in that particular fashion,
the story within the story?
I mean, it's just done
so beautifully.
And I love it when someone
can do it, you know?
And you manage to have someone --
also love stories where
a character gets to talk.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah.
>> Brad Watson: You know?
Gets to have long periods
of speaking
and it's perfectly
natural within the story.
It doesn't seem imposed or
awkward or anything like that.
>> Bill Roorbach: Oh, thanks.
>> Brad Watson: You
set that up perfectly.
That's one of my favorite
stories in the book, really.
>> Bill Roorbach: Well, just
growing up I was like --
I grew up in Connecticut -- and, you
know, at that time it was woodsy,
there were still some farms,
but there were also --
it's ex-urban New York.
So there's some lots of big estates
with big stone mansions
and that kind of thing.
And I had a secret scheme
to get out of school,
which a couple of us
figured this out.
You would just -- because one of our
friends moved and he brought a note
from his mother that said,
"We're moving as of April 3rd."
[ Laughter ]
And the kid gave it to the teacher,
the teacher said, "Oh my goodness.
Well, we'll have a
party and say goodbye."
And so off he went.
And I thought, you know,
anyone could do that.
[ Laughter ]
So I never did it,
but I never forgot
that great scam that I -- you know?
And I just dreamed that I would go
off in the woods every day instead
of going to school, you know,
which is also how I operated
as a college professor for so long.
But through the woods, through our
woods you had to walk for, like,
a mile but you came to
an old carriage house.
And you knew you were on the such
and such estate, the Erwin estate.
And then up the hill was this giant
mansion, and we'd sneak around there
and play war games and
look in the windows.
And we never got caught.
But for the story I just
thought, "What if they got caught?
What if a kid got caught?"
So he does skip school,
he does get caught.
And the old guy isn't a threatening
guy but someone who takes him
under his wing and has
finally found his audience
for his really horrible story
of the destruction of his life
in Russia during the
Russian Revolution.
So the story takes place in 1963
and the old story takes place 1905.
So that's where that came from.
>> Brad Watson: There's so
many beautiful moments, though,
when the count -- the
way that the old count,
we don't know he's
the old count now,
we think he's under
his assumed name --
but the way he tells the
story in third person.
And when you begin to become aware
that he's speaking of himself
and his wife and his children
dying in this way or that way.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah.
>> Brad Watson: And then the boy,
and he says, "Well, what shall we do
with these poor souls
who are departed?
Let us take them to Sweden."
I don't know, is that the
boy's idea or is that the --
>> Bill Roorbach: Oh, yeah.
The old guy's got a box of --
>> Brad Watson: He had a big map.
He's got a gigantic map of Europe.
>> Bill Roorbach: And he's
got little characters in a box
that are all the people
from his life that are dead,
including all of his children, all
of his mother's father's uncles,
aunts, all of his sisters
and brothers.
Everyone's --
>> Brad Watson: His father.
>> Bill Roorbach: Everyone's dead,
but he has these little
models of them.
And the little boy picks out
people as he tells a story
and flies them off to the graveyard.
>> Brad Watson: He said,
"Let us fly them to Sweden."
>> Bill Roorbach: Let's
fly them to Sweden.
>> Brad Watson: He
takes them to Sweden.
And there's all over there.
And I love the moment
when he says, "Well,
now there's the old count also
who dies early in the skirmish.
Who shall we choose,
which figurine?"
And the boy picks one
out, "Excellent choice."
And you know that's the
father is the right count.
It's a beautiful story.
It has moments like that through,
I mean, all of these stories.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah.
I'm not trying to make condensed
novels because they do feel
like a different impulse
from a novel.
Like, I always know when I'm
in a story versus a novel.
And I know what material's
going to be good
for a story as opposed to novel.
But yeah. There's some
way I built --
someone said that and I
was like, "Oh yeah, okay.
That makes sense."
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
That always reminds me of that
Lars Gustafsson story, you know,
he has this beautiful story
Greatness Strikes Where It Pleases.
And most people found out
because Charles Baxter put it in,
"You got to read this."
Yeah, you know?
And so my wife actually studied with
Lars at Texas for a while and said
to him one time, "Yeah, Lars,
how did you write that story?"
And he said, "Yes, how did I do it?"
[ Laughter ]
That's all he could say.
>> Bill Roorbach: Well,
part of it is magic, right?
Part of it is --
>> Brad Watson: Right.
>> Bill Roorbach: -- it's you're
really dreaming your way into it.
I always say that writing is the
slowest form of reading, you know?
[ Laughter ]
It's just I want to find out
what's going to happen, too.
Even if I know what's
going to happen at the end,
how it gets there,
that's interesting, too.
That's a different kind
of suspense, you know, so.
>> Brad Watson: I know.
Well, I was talking earlier to you
about how I love the way
you pace the title story,
which is the last story in the
collection The Girl of the Lake.
I mean, one time that Kathy read it
and thought maybe it was
moving a little slowly,
but I didn't think so.
I thought the pacing
was just wonderfully --
it had a revolution, you know?
It's kind of like there was an RPM
to the story that felt right to it.
And I just -- I rolled
with it and rolled with it.
And I was never impatient for
the next moment, you know,
even though they are full
of tension when [inaudible].
>> Bill Roorbach: Because
some of the stories are
like bang, bang, bang, bang, bang.
And that one is just
let it unfold, right?
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah.
>> Brad Watson: It's a good way --
I thought also a good
story to end the book,
even though it's traditional sort
of to do the title story last,
it's a good choice in itself.
>> Bill Roorbach: Yeah, as
Brad said, my editor was like,
"Maybe you can tighten it up.
It's a little slow."
And I thought, "No, let's
let it be slow," I mean --
and she's like, "Well,
people's patience has changed.
You know. people -- I'm like,
"Well, let's slow them down."
>> Brad Watson: Yeah [Laughs].
>> Bill Roorbach: I mean,
there's other fast-paced stories,
just let me have one
that's just really --
[ Multiple Speakers ]
We just have ten minutes left.
>> Brad Watson: Oh, you
better read something.
>> Bill Roorbach: I'll
just read a page.
>> Brad Watson: I look too long.
>> Bill Roorbach: No, you did fine.
You're beautiful.
You're a beautiful man.
[ Laughter ]
At breakfast on one of those --
this is from the title
story The Girl of the Lake.
And this young man's at the
family cabin with his grandmother,
only two of them this summer -- at
breakfast on one of the perfect days
of mid-August, still
no notion in the wind
that the season might ever end,
grandma asked Chick
if we wanted E-Cough.
Chick laughed, "E-Cough?"
he said. "E-Cough," said Grandma."
"I don't drink E-Cough, Grandma."
She grinned sheepishly, charmingly,
laughed at herself,
and that had been that.
At lunch she said,
"Look at me, Charles."
And Chick looked a long while.
She looked so beautiful, so
square and strong and happy.
After dinner, which was one
of Mr. Parmenter's chickens
roasted perfectly, tiny potatoes,
string beans with almonds, chocolate
cake, a delicate discussion
about her favorite music
versus Chick's Italian opera --
not so different from
Miles Davis, they decided,
at least in its effects on the soul.
She said she had a
drumming headache.
The next morning she stood
vacantly in the kitchen,
simply stared at Chick, a
block of raw bacon in her hand.
"Grandma?"
She grinned sheepishly,
said nothing.
"Grandma?"
Chick accepted the bacon
from her, put it back on ice,
gathered her up in his arms --
surprisingly heavy for
such a little bird --
enveloped her and heaved
her up the walk to the Jeep,
sat her in the passenger seat
where she retained her posture.
One time his sister
had gotten stitches
from a doctor somewhere near,
but he had no idea where or who.
Of course, there was no phone.
He drove carefully up the
hump driveway to Race Road,
pulled out over the potholes at
the proper speed to beat them,
drove stiffly 12 miles
to Beamis Corners --
25 long minutes without
conversation.
At the gas station, he pulled
in and honked loud and long.
Mina flounced out,
annoyed at the honking
until she saw Chick and blushed.
He asked politely where
he might find a hospital.
She looked at him closely,
then at grandma.
"Oh my," she said, "The
hospital's in Keene [phonetic].
It's 20 miles.
Mrs. Flexheart?
Is there a doctor?"
"In Keene," I said.
Chick began to panic.
He said, "How do I find it?"
"Oh dear," Philomena said.
She patted his arms,
eyes sparkling with care.
In a rush she said,
"I'll go with you."
She called to her father,
who hurried from the garage
at her tone, wrenches in hand.
The girl quickly explained
Mrs. Flexheart was ill.
Her father was as urgent as
she, tears starting to his eyes.
Everyone loved grandma.
Philomena climbed in the back
seat and gave directions.
Chick had never driven on a highway
but found it easy once he got used
to all the cars passing
him, all the honking.
Mina leaned forward,
held grandma's shoulders,
said, "Speed up a little."
But it was hard for Chick
to go over the speed limit.
Mr. Parmenter had told him for
Race Road 30 miles an hour.
The girl smelled of gasoline.
She put a hand on Chick's
shoulder, too.
Her hair was red in the mirror, her
cheeks streaked with engine grease.
He used the mirror to catch her
bright green eye for reassurance.
Grandma sat very still.
Thinking of other disasters
and still with no preamble,
Chick unburdened himself, said, "I
saw the Shaunessy girl out there."
"I've seen her, too,"
Mina said matter of fact,
knowing what he meant by out there.
Spruce Island, of course.
She said, "Anya Shaunessy, she's so
beautiful, isn't she -- wasn't she?
And her dog, I was
frightened of them, though.
Purely silent, that loverly dress.
I dropped my bucket and
ran right for the boat.
No one believed me."
She tightened her grip
on his shoulder.
The trip took 40 minutes,
but they made Keene,
grandma's posture perfect
the whole ride.
She was silent and unblinking,
but she breathed well
and Chick knew she'd be okay.
At the emergency room
entrance he pulled
up perfectly, set the parking brake.
He and Mina went to help grandma
out, but despite the straight spine
and high chin, the open
eyes, she was unmoving.
Boy and girl hefted the old woman,
carried her into the
emergency room lobby.
Two nurses scurried to their sides
as they lay their burden
on the floor.
A doctor rushed in, and then a
couple of orderlies in blue scrubs
who lifted grandma onto
their gurney in a calm hurry.
But after a few busy minutes,
the doctor just stopped.
He set his chin, looked at Chick.
The orderlies relaxed.
"I'm sorry," one of the nurses said.
Philomena burst into hot
tears; Chick then, too.
Shocked and weeping, standing among
strangers, it was only natural
that he and Mina caught one
another in a tight embrace,
the nurse then folding
them both in her own arms,
then an orderly joining
in, then the doctor --
a long group hug, protocol
abandoned,
all of them in their humanity.
Mina's father arrived with
Mr. Parmenter in short order.
Chick had never seen a man cry
like Mr. Parmenter cried
when he heard the news.
The old bird dropped to
his knees, held his face,
sobbed and gulped inconsolably,
so devastated that even an hour
later he couldn't drive the Jeep
home but had to ride with
Mr. Hardy, Mina and Chick
in the broad back seat of
the mechanic's ancient Woody,
her foot hooked stealthily
around Chick's calf,
their fingers tightly interlaced,
sweaty after a while,
almost painful, too.
It didn't matter.
They weren't going to let go.
[ Applause ]
Well, thanks.
>> Brad Watson: I am just --
yeah, I love that scene very much.
And, you know, I say that that
story's not the only story
that does it in the book, but
you have a way of ending a story
that people don't often use anymore,
and you do it beautifully
and it's so satisfying.
I'm not going to say what it
is so that people will have
to buy your book in
order to figure it out.
[ Laughter ]
But that's one of them, yeah.
And the title story is one.
And --
>> Bill Roorbach: And
it's a ghost story.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Tuck a ghost in there, too.
>> Brad Watson: Yeah, the
Shaunessy girl is a ghost.
>> Bill Roorbach: You put a novel
and you're really committed --
but a ghost in, you're
really committed.
But in a story you put a
ghost in and you only have
to justify it for 20 or 30 pages.
[ Laughter ]
But it was fun to make
stories for the same reason.
Because a novel, again, is
such a years' long commitment.
And the stories I make,
it's interstitial among
everything else I'm working on.
So I write books and
then I write a story.
So these stories are
written over ten years
and then revisited to make a book.
They've all been published
various places,
but it was fun to go back to them.
And being a new writer, you
know, you change every year.
I brought new things to
every story, you know?
I tinkered with the endings, and in
some cases I really changed them.
You know, so.
Any last thoughts?
>> Brad Watson: Because
we're going to kill you.
>> Bill Roorbach: No.
[ Laughter ]
That came out wrong,
any last thoughts?
We've already had our last meal.
[ Laughter ]
>> Brad Watson: Right.
>> Bill Roorbach: The
egg on the tacos.
>> Brad Watson: Bill's
tacos with an egg.
>> Bill Roorbach: Miss Jane is --
you know, when you're a writer,
so many of your friends
are writers, right?
And there are just constantly
books coming in, constantly.
>> Brad Watson: Because
somebody's got to buy them.
>> Bill Roorbach: And you read
them with trepidation, you know?
You're like, "What if
I don't like this?"
And you don't always
like them very much.
You know? But yeah, you have to
find some language to say, you know,
"I read your book and
congratulations."
You know? So I read this,
the start of this book,
and immediately was gripped.
And I read it in one long sitting,
just tears in my eyes the whole way.
It's so beautiful.
It's such a great book.
And it's so great to have
a friend do me the favor
of writing a great book.
[ Laughter ]
So I can just turn to him and say,
"That book is fucking great, Brad."
>> Brad Watson: So is your
book, it's fucking great.
>> Bill Roorbach: There we go.
We love each other.
Thank you very much.
>> Brad Watson: Thanks very much.
>> Bill Roorbach: And thank
the Library of Congress, too.
>> Brad Watson: yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Brad Watson: And one
last thing, I just --
you know sometimes you
feel like you got to rest
between stories or pause, you know?
It's really hard to
do that with this one.
You just want to read another, Bill.
>> Bill Roorbach: Oh, thanks.
You're really great.
We're going to sell some of
them downstairs, I guess.
So -- I don't know.
Come and say hi.
We'll be down there to talk, too.
>> Brad Watson: Yeah.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.